you and I share something in common
we're both very beautiful when very tall
yeah we hit it off
I remember we first met we hit it off it
was just really related hopefully
married yeah I have to make one phone
call to get this done yeah yeah I'm
ready I'm waiting I am there but you
know what else is that there's so many
women can sort of put a hat down and and
not be noticed but you're very striking
you're very tall you know yeah of me I'm
not blending anytime yeah I mean I often
think in kind of the most mundane
situations of course no one would ever
recognize me I went to the dentist I was
having a a horrific root canal the
dentists II went through I was
traumatized he left the room the dental
nurse was there the clamp was in my
mouth she was peering in and I was there
sort of gripping and I thought she was
about to offer me some soothing words
and instead I get tell me what happens
in Game of Thrones their prostrate being
tortured yeah there's a lot there's a
lot of boons so this jobs a lot of plus
points right was was torture in dental
chair
[Laughter]
you